loved him in mad men back in the day
his new show premieres on amc plus
on mondays and then that uh episode
airs on amc proper the next monday
following it's called the beast must die
which i think is in reference to denmark
uh because england plays denmark in now
37 minutes from this very moment jared
harris
joining us here on the rich eisen show
how are you jared
not a good segue that one thank you sir
very well thank you
i'm trying to bring my a game like uh
england
because i i i
heard you were saying my comments from
two years ago yes
very different england side very
different
would you i mean my gosh jerry somehow i
i
sense in your tone rich a certain
gleefulness that you don't expect us to
come through and meet the italians
oh no the final i i think a certain
sudden
no i'm wrong of mine oh you are jared i
am so
rooting so hard for you and england
and i love watching this team uh i
i do i love watching this side i do love
i love sterling i love
you know what i love i love the the
keeper jordan pickford i know plays for
everton
uh i just love the way that he barks at
the defense like how dare they allow a
ball get to him
for him to stop i just i love all of it
yeah
i love southgate's suits i love it all i
love i love
every last thing about what i'm seeing i
wonder what you think jared
i i love the suit quite right um
uh i i i would join i'm enjoying a lot i
think we uh
uh we we you know you have to defend
from the uh
from the front you have to defend from
the front line so then we're playing
much better as a team
um you know a little cautious but listen
you can't question the way that we've
gotten there so see what happens today
denmark a very good side
they all say the emotional favorites so
they'll have um
you know they will they will fight right
up to the final whistle so
i think it's gonna be a tough game and
um
denmark and school and hopefully we've
got our scoring boots on
i was very impressed by harry kane in
the last match i have to say i think
he's been getting some bad
press um and uh i i think he's a
phenomenal player and an old striker his
touch is amazing and his vision
vision is fantastic well didn't he just
tie alan shearer for the most
goals in international competition in
the history of english football
i mean isn't he he's going to wind up
being the the most prolific scorer all
the
time
right yeah i mean he's uh what's
probably
so it sounds like to me again it's hard
to keep up with i mean you're
it sounds like again uh i don't know
because you you
you you do sound like you're trying not
to get your hopes too high
at this point jared harris am i correct
in assuming that about
yes yes
you know decades of being an england
supporter you've learned that lesson
[Laughter]
get your hopes up okay so um
now all of us here are our jared harris
here on the rich eisen show we are just
assuming
uh this is what we're hoping right this
is what we're hoping we are hoping
that you're phoning in right now from a
private car
that's taking you from the federer match
at wimbledon to go to wembley
to see this in person in london is that
at all possible remotely possible that
this is how
you're spending your day today jared
harris
well i i personally think even better
i'm actually in florida
by the um uh the beautiful
atlantic ocean okay having been lightly
brushed by
tropical storm elsa okay um and the
plants who uh watched the match
uh here at this lovely house my wife uh
has rented
okay so that's how you were taking in
this mat just you and your wife that's
it
yeah we have a friend it is over for the
day so yeah
okay is your friend aware that there
will be lots of screaming
television i just want i'm just
wondering your friend is aware
that what's happening in 33 minutes time
correct
he knows in fact in fact what a leg when
normally what she does is
she waits for the most like humorous and
embarrassing moment
who calls them on her phone and then
post them to her twitter account
oh this is phenomenal jared harris here
on the rich eisen show on a very big day
for
for english football i mean what talk
about the timing so
uh tell me about the beast must die
jared uh i'm a again i'm a big fan of
anything that you do so um um i'm
assuming
most will be just like me locked into
whatever you're up to so
tell me about this show and what uh what
attracted you to do it
for amc thank you
thank you yeah it's uh it's a it's a
thriller it's a thriller to suspend
story
it's a revenge drama um
a a woman's uh her her son
has been killed in a hit-and-run
accident the police have basically
um exhausted all of their leads and
they've given up
and so she decides to take the matter
into her own hands
and she decides that she's going to find
out who did it
who killed her son and she's going to
kill them so it's a sort of
vendetta revenge story and then you know
the and the uh
she she puts together who she thinks is
a likely culprit
and then i guess the sort of the drama
is is
is this the right person does she have
the right house
and will he figure out what she's really
up to before she figures out
if he's the person that she's there she
needs to kill
so it's a good cat and mouth game and
it's also i mean
that's the plot but i mean what it's
really about is this
examination of grief out of um and of
loss
um and chris jumbo gives
an absolutely stunning remarkable
performance
um and as do everybody in in the story
but
she it's cheaply her story
i'm possibly i am the beast that might
need to die or maybe i'm not i don't
know
okay see you one must tune in one must
tune in
premiere on amc plus uh this past monday
and then it will premiere on next monday
on amc at 10 p.m and
uh all episodes will continue to debut
on amc plus a week ahead of the amc
linear airings mondays at 10 eastern
time and this was all
shot on the isle of wight as well
correct shot uh on location
jared it was yeah okay yeah
it was um it was shot yeah the isle of
wight we shot it
you know drove full blown during the
pandemic but the isle of wight is a
summer uh vacation destination and
because of the
the the uh the pandemic it never really
opened up
it was actually a very safe place to go
to and one of the
you know one of the successful things
that we were able to do
was to prove that it was actually it one
is able to safely
operate and safely shoot under those
circumstances
so um it was a good example to the
industry that um
you know with the with the right
precautions taken it it can continue
and ask the other question is what drew
me to it to me
which is always the same thing the
quality of the writing
you know i it's the the first and
foremost a good
script and gabby cape is a wonderful
writer
and um you you immediately know within
the first
10 pages of reading her script that she
knows exactly what she's doing
and she knows what stories she wants to
tell
she's interested in telling she has a
voice she has a point of view
so that's what you're looking for all
right i am jared harris here on the rich
eisen show
uh making uh another appearance here
which i i greatly appreciate you were in
person last time so
this is your second time here so i i i i
think you understand that
i think you understand that you know of
course the show is is
you know about pop culture and sports
and we try to have
a reasonable sensibility to it jared but
that said it is still a sports talk show
as well
so this might be a little bit out there
uh so i'll ask you anyway since you're
the perfect person
okay uh more of a disaster the super
league or chernobyl
[Laughter]
jared what's more of a complete disaster
wow
what do you think well i mean
i would say the the the response
to the super league disaster swift
and um a lot thrifted to the the the
response to the chernobyl disaster yes
and as such it was you know contained
and caused your eyes before it
it really caused a lot more problems um
right
yes obviously the chernobyl disaster is
an ongoing problem an ongoing disaster
there's still children being born in
belarus who have
genetic uh deformities because of their
the exposure
um uh to to the radiation so
obviously the human element of it is
where you're bringing it in and
um you know i i should probably pay a
bit more more attention that
the sports aspect of it um all that said
uh wha what were your thoughts because
one of your
your club was uh kind of at the
forefront of that
of all that what a mess what a mess that
was
i mean i always going to be a
non-starter
and um just a a complete
i mean to me what i think i looked again
so i bet you what
what what happened was the negotiations
between those teams took
so long to sort out that they didn't
have time to come up with a pr strategy
because that was a complete
mess yes it was an absolute mess
and the idea that um it was ever gonna
fly was ridiculous because
no no football player is gonna play for
a club
if they're gonna get banned for playing
for their country because
the the ultimate goal of every
footballer is to win the world cup
yes so if they're going to be if they'll
be banned by the fa for playing for the
national side no one's going to sign up
so
it was a it's a non-starter from the
beginning oh my gosh
i'm i'm so you know i'm nervous for you
coming up in 26 minutes time jared i'm
i'm really i'm nervous for you
um so in the final minutes that that we
have here
um what just paint me the picture do you
do are there gonna be snacks um do you
do you not
do you consume anything during during
the match or what do you got what what's
the jared harris uh
viewing situation actual uh you told me
where you are and who you're with but
what's up here's a treasure
well i need a pina colada
okay that's a good start um uh
and some uh we have some good old
english sausages i think
okay um yeah
oh my gosh it's like this like and
uh and chips are you sure you're not in
claridges
and you switch with salad cream dipping
wow i know it sounds ridiculous but with
a salad cream
they'd never have that clarity but yeah
it does sound pretty good
you sure you're only having one guest
yard that sounds like your plus two
i know it does it is a bit of an
overkill
um so what's your prediction what do you
think's gonna happen oh i think harry
kane's gonna put you in a rocking chair
and about
five minutes in i think he's gonna get
this thing started you guys are locked
in
and i hope i don't put the ziggy on you
but um
i think this is how do you you can't
lose in wembley this is it
set up i just said that yes i just said
that
i just said that to an englishman i
literally just said that yeah
i know but this is right the humiliation
yeah i think um
i i i mean i i i've noticed that that
the last three of the last four games we
hit the post in the first fight but it
would be nice one of those to go in
but um but denmark have a tremendous
fight in spirit
you know getting a goal up is not going
to be they're not going to
you won't crush that spirit so i think i
think this
is definitely going to go to the wire
okay i only hope you please can it not
go to penalties
oh god um it has to be uh
resolved extra time that's fine but
please
no penalty i know that is the that is
the wound that will never be cauterized
in england
maybe how about this just for you and i
appreciate you you're spending this time
uh
you know with everything churning inside
um
how about how about uh manchester united
club captain harry maguire
he puts one in the back of the net to
get things started and it's it's one of
your guys
for your team and your nation and you're
going to be just chilling with cucumber
sandwiches and sausages and
and pina coladas and florida sunsets and
all that stuff how about that for the
day
jared how about that let's do it let's
do it from your mouth
you're from your mouth sterling's right
foot
harry maguire's head yes by the way if
that happens
we're calling you we're calling you back
don't worry we're gonna get you back on
um thank you jared i appreciate the call
i love the chat i think i just say yes
please
i don't think anyone i think it's going
to be hard for anybody to be italy in
the finals
they are playing superb football
look one at a time jared and you're
gonna take it all out you're gonna take
them all out this is your time
okay i feel it i hate you i hear you
you're quite right rick
quite right right let's go
come on chair let's go here we go all
right let's go jared you are a lead pipe
wheeling professional
amc can't say to you that you didn't go
out and do your best and do your hardest
to promote the beast must die
your butt your your blood's flowing you
got butterflies in your stomach and
you're calling into
this show to you know to promote your
show this is it you're
you're a per you're a pipeline
professional jared harris
you're a pro thank you people don't
realize how hard this job
is
he's got a 10 course meal in a florida
house i love it
fantastic send us a photo yes enjoy
enjoy the match jared let's chat again
soon i really enjoyed it thank you
okay have a good one you go for it
all right go england here we go jared
harris at jared harris on twitter and
instagram
three lions rich we're coming home three
lines here they come the beast must die
the three lions
kill the beast let's go there's nothing
rotten
here we go hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here